he looked at her longingly as he
imagined her exotic mashed potatoes skin
laying gently against his his skin
glistening the Sun like a glazed
doughnut the glazed part not the
doughnut part she didn't know it yet but
the girl of her dreams had just walked
in her eyes were radiant and her skin
glowed with mozzarella undertones he
traced his fingers along her supple
cauliflower skin his body had the colour
and shape of raw ground beef she was
beautiful
elegant like a tall clear glass filled
of raw pasta she had brown wiry hair and
skin that could only be described as the
colour of the inside of an apple the
mushy ones not the cool crisp ones she
was transfixed by the gleam of her
uncooked chicken breast skin so raw her
beauty was indescribable which means
she's white who would play me in such a
rom-com of your life
she teasingly inquired you have such
beautiful olive skin he crude so you can
be a person of color or racially
ambiguous in the book but definitely a
white woman in the movie